Right now the paradigm is you
have one rover for one mission.
So if that rover were
to fail or break down,
the whole mission is over.
In order to avoid
this, we resort
to a paradigm where we use
multiple miniaturized assets,
which you can deploy in
different areas on the planet,
even into high risk areas,
which are especially
important for scientists.
If you lose a few in
the cause of doing so,
you still have a mission.
Because some of them will for
sure make it into the areas
where you want to go.
The main motivation
for us scientists
is to explore the unknown.
That's always been the
mantra for humanity.
To push the envelope, to go
where nobody has gone before.
One of the main questions
which humanity has been asking
is, are we alone?
So the quest for the search
for life outside the Earth.